escrimeuse danseuse gymnastes et non
professionnels toutes ces sportifs
guyancourt toise ont été mises en valeur
par le photographe des ânes
l'exposition qui fêtera ses 1 en mars
prochain continue à vivre et s'offrent
d'une tournée des gymnases j'ai
découvert en fait les rudiments de la
photo sportive
donc ils appellent de s'adapter mais en
même temps la photo sportive le
mouvement
mais énormément de grâce plus habitué
aux portraits posés l'artiste s'est
essayé au mouvement
à chaque à chaque sport qui a été une
découverte un défi une technique d'
approche une technique d' approche non
je paye de sport favori pour pour faire
ces photos ça et c'est vraiment la
découverte plus à chaque fois s'adapter
aux mouvements de sport photographies
mais aussi à la sportive des ânes a
rencontré une grande partie des
associations sportives depuis en cours
pour trouver ces volontaires c'est
beaucoup plus gênant pour une femme de
se faire regarder reprennent faire des
mouvements doivent se sentir ce que je
fais mal et ce que je fais pas mal
surtout qu'en fait c'étaient
principalement tout des nos vies il n'y
a aucune à tête aux professionnels sur
c'est sur ces photos l'artiste est
revenu à ses premiers amours effet
essentiellement des portraits
aujourd'hui pour ne jamais frustré
d'inspiration soudaine son
appareil-photo l'accompagnent dans
toutes ses sorties